liebe leute wenn ich mir so eure
kommentare anschaue dann habt ihr ein
ganz schön großes problem
[Musik]
deswegen werden wir heute über
blattläuse sprechen und da werde ich dir
vier methoden an die hand geben mit
denen du den blattläusen her werden
kannst deinen garten endlich zurück
erobert gegen diese heerscharen von
blattläusen wir gerade bei dir einfallen
aber bevor wir mit den tipps loslegen
sprechen wir erst mal über blattläuse an
sich es ist nämlich ganz klug als
gärtner zu wissen zumindest ganz grob
wie die sich dann im garten ausbreiten
was die über wollen und wann sie
schädlich sind und wann nicht natürlich
sieht es erstmal schrecklich aus wenn
die ganzen pflanzen voller blattläuse
hängen
an sich ist das aber erstmal gar nicht
so ein großes problem denn blattläuse
neben wie alle tiere in unserem garten
eine rolle in unserem ökosystem ein und
sind für die pflanzen gar nicht so
schädlich wie man meinen mag natürlich
sagen sie an den pflanzen und schwächen
die pflanzen damit aber eher mit einem
geringen blank lausbefall kommen die
pflanzen schon noch zurecht was manchmal
problematisch ist ist das blatt läuse
krankheiten übertragen können also es
ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll was gegen
blattläuse zu unternehmen aber kein
grund in panik zu verfallen oder das
gärtnern zu verfluchen sind auf einmal
sowie die platte also bei dir auftauchen
denn das ist ganz normal das ist kein
weltuntergang und du kannst dagegen
etwas unternehmen so dass dein garten
hoffentlich bald wieder viel hübscher
aussieht bestimmt hast du schon mal
beobachtet dass manche blattläuse flügel
haben während andere keine flüge haben
das passiert immer dann wenn es den
blattläusen nicht so gut geht wenn zum
beispiel viele marienkäfer in deinem
garten unterwegs sind die ja blattläuse
fressen dann reagieren die blattläuse
ganz mart und die nächste generation hat
dann einfach flügel so dass sie vor den
marienkäfern wegfliegen können und neue
pflanzen aufsuchen können oder wenn zu
wenig platz auf der pflanze ist wenn es
der pflanze nicht so gut geht dann
entstehen eben diese blattläuse die
fliegen können und die daneben louis
schwirren
und noch andere pflanzen in deinem
garten oder in der umgebung befallen
werden und so treten die sich dann in
deinem garten aus das ist eigentlich
ziemlich clever von denen oder also ganz
egal wie viel ärger blattläuse einem
bringen
sie sind schon faszinierende geschöpfe
und ich bin es immer ganz spannend zu
beobachten wisst ihr denn eigentlich so
treiben viele von euch wissen
wahrscheinlich dass ameisen sich
blattläuse als honig erhalten das heißt
wir gehen zu den blattläusen hin
die verteilen um die blattläuse drum
herum einen stoff der sieben macht damit
sie eben nicht wegfliegen und schön da
bleiben wo sie sind weil die blattläuse
eben ein zucker saft ab sondern die
ameisen total gerne trinken und die acht
waisen gehen sogar so weit dass sie den
gleisen die flügel abbeißen damit sie
nicht abhauen können ganz schön fies
eigentlich ein bisschen sklavenhaltung
oder aber dafür beschützen die ameisen
dem auch und fressen zum beispiel
marienkäferlarven oder töten die
zumindest weiß nicht ob sie dann auch
essen
damit die nicht die blattläuse
auffressen es ist schon so ein bisschen
eine symbiose aber wenn man mal so genau
hinschaut ist es schon eine form der
sklavenhaltung findet ihr nicht ich
würde deswegen jetzt nicht so weit gehen
und ameisen töten die in deinem garten
unterwegs sind wenn sie jetzt nicht noch
auf andere art und weise riesige schäden
anrichten aber was du machen kannst ist
wenn du einen ameisenbau findest und du
siehst die sind ständig an den
blattläusen und beflügeln das ganze auch
noch also sorgen dafür dass deine
pflanzen noch weiter von den blattläusen
befallen sind dann kannst du den
bauausgaben in einen blumentopf bringen
und irgendwo in einer weit entfernte
gartenecke umsiedeln so dass das
möglichst nicht mehr passiert aber viel
mehr würde ich gegen die ameisen nicht
unternehmen
die ja auch sehr nützliche funktionen im
garten übernehmen
vielleicht interessiert ihr euch auch
einfach kein bisschen für blattläuse und
was die so den ganzen tag treiben und
wollte einfach nur tipps haben wie ihr
die denn jetzt endlich los werden könnte
und da fangen wir mal mit einem tipp an
der langfristig wirkt aber eben sehr
wichtig ist und der bedeutet dass du
deinen garten so gestalten solltest das
nützlinge also fressfeinde der
blattläuse auch in deinem garten ein
zuhause finden
ratlos hat ganz ganz viele fressfeinde
ich muss da jetzt mal auf meine schlaue
liste schauen damit ich die alle
zusammen kriege das ist einmal natürlich
der marienkäfer dann schlüpft westen
gaal mücken schwebfliegen florfliegen
raubwanzen spinnen käfer ohren kneifen
und sogar für gelassen alle ganz
nützlinge die sich entweder von den
blattläusen ernähren oder sie als wirte
für ihre eiablage nutzen und damit eben
auch zur dezimierung der blattläuse
beitragen und ein naturnaher garten dem
es vielleicht auch meinen laubhaufen in
der ecke gibt in dem es eine
trockenmauer gibt in dem hacken sind in
denen sich viele tiere wohlfühlen in dem
es vielleicht auch totholz haufen gibt
auch insektenhotels sind natürlich eine
tolle möglichkeit und sehen vielleicht
ein bisschen ordentlicher auch ist so
ein garten ist natürlich super um all
diese nützlinge in deinem garten zu
locken und damit kannst du dir so viel
arbeit sparen im biogarten indem du
einfach darauf 8 ist das ja das nicht
ein reiner nutzgarten ist sondern eben
auch ein lebensraum für alle möglichen
insekten und andere tiere die sich in
deinem garten ansiedeln sollten damit
sie diese lästige feine wie die
blattlaus vormals halten aber auch mit
mischkultur kannst du eine menge
erreichen ihr wisst dass ich bin ein
riesen fan davon beete in mischkultur zu
bepflanzen das heißt pflanzen
nebeneinander zu setzen die sich
entweder schädlinge vom leib halten oder
krankheiten vom leib halten und da gibt
es einige pflanzen die duh supergut in
deinem garten anbauen kannst oben
blattläuse fern
das sind vor allem kräuter und ich
pflanze die super gerne in meinem ganzen
garten einfach entlang der wege in die
gemüsebeete da habe ich super gute
erfahrungen mit gemacht denn kräuter vor
allem diejenigen die ich euch jetzt
gleichauf liste haben ja oft ein sehr
aromatischen duft der schädlinge fährten
hält und gegen blattläuse hilft vor
allem bohnenkraut thymian oregano und
lavendel das sind ja alles kräuter die
man sowieso gerne an bord oder ich mein
team - so ziemlich das tollste kraut
überhaupt ist es sich total gerne davon
kann ich gar nicht genug haben und wenn
das soeben noch die funktion erfüllt den
garten vor blattläusen zu schützen dann
nichts mehr damit und ab in die
gemüsebeete das ist eine super tolle
sache und das sieht auch total schön aus
wenn man die beete ränder mit kräutern
gepflanzt
[Musik]
dann gibt es noch eine ganz tolle
pflanze die gegen blattläuse hilft das
ist die kapuzinerkresse die wird zwar
nicht so wie die kräuter in dem sie duft
verströmt der blattläuse abschreckt
sondern sie ist ein wahrer blattlaus
magnet und ich habe das ganz oft in
meinem garten erlebt dass wir nur an der
kapuzinerkresse blattläuse hatten weil
die sich alle darauf gestürzt haben das
war sozusagen die opfer pflanze und die
restlichen pflanzen wurden verschont
also auf jeden fall ein tolles zeug man
die kapuziner klasse blüten kann man ja
auch wunderbar in den salat parken das
ist eine super schöne pflanze aber sie
hat eben auch diesen wundervollen effekt
dass sie die gleise von dem anderen
gemüse- oder von den anderen pflanzen
abhängt ja aber was wenn jetzt schon
super viele blattläuse an den pflanzen
sitzen und du brauchst jetzt verdammt
noch mal einen tipp marie was man jetzt
unternehmen kann wenn es denn schon zu
spät ist wenn keine nützlinge in sicht
sind und die beete jetzt einfach
gefallen sind und man muss jetzt was
unternehmen da will ich dir einmal
empfehlen eine schmierseife lösung
anzusetzen das ist ganz einfach gemacht
du nimmst einfach ein liter wasser packs
da ungefähr 25 gramm schmierseife rein
vermischt das ordentlich und dann spürst
du das auch die pflanzen darauf direkt
auf die blattläuse und das wiederholst
du dann alle paar tage da solltest du
für ein super gute erfolge sehen dann
gibt es noch einen vierten trägt er
funktioniert sehr ähnlich du kannst auch
pflanzen jahren ansetzen einfach eine
prämie ist ja auch ein toller dünger
sollte man eh zu handhaben stinkt aber
ein bisschen aber kleiner tipp da
einfach ein bisschen urgesteins mit rein
geben dann ist schon viel verträglicher
gerade wenn man nachbarn hat die
vielleicht ein bisschen empfindlich sind
wie ich hatte in meinem allerersten
garten immer wandels skrupel brennen sie
ja auch alles umsetzen weil ich immer
angst hatte dass die irgendwann mal
richtig ärger deswegen kriegen aber seit
ich da uli steins mehr rein mache hat
sich auf jeden fall noch niemand
beschwert und ich finde es auch viel
angenehmer dann damit zu arbeiten
die sache ist nur wenn man pflanzen mit
jauche besprüht dann ist es für die
pflanzen ziemlich heftig also auch ist
schon in crysis zeug deswegen wollen wir
eine sehr junge
ansetzen da nimmst du pro liter wasser
100 gramm brennesseln die packst du da
rein dass sie über nacht in dem wasser
ziehen dann siehst du das ab und dann
kannst du diese brühe ich weiß nicht ob
man es jetzt schon sache nennen kann
diesen kaltwasser auszug kannst du dann
unverdient auf deine pflanzen sprühen
aber nicht länger ziehen lassen denn
dann müsstest du schon noch stärker
verdünnten bzw
eignet sich das war nicht mehr so toll
um das dann wirklich auf die pflanzen zu
sprühen also da besser nur eine ganz
junge verwenden ist auch toll wenn man
nicht so lange warten muss oder besetzt
ist an einem tag an
dann kannst du am nächsten tag schon
loslegen und deine blattläuse damit zum
dollar trimmel ja das wiederholst du
dann alle paar tage einfach immer wieder
direkt auf die blattläuse sprühen und
dann solltest du schon nach spätestens
einer woche die ersten erfolge sehen bzw
schon so gut wie blood los freie
pflanzen haben ein ganz blattlaus freier
garten wer jetzt finde ich nicht so
erstrebenswert die gehören wie gesagt
einfach dazu die haben auch ihre
berechtigung aber wenn sie in massen
auftreten wenn man das gemüse auch nicht
mehr essen mag weil überall die böden
blattläuse draufsetzen
dann ist schonzeit was zu unternehmen
und da würde ich dir diese beiden sachen
auf jeden fall empfehlen um schnell
wirken tut etwas gegen deinen blatt
lausbefall zu unternehmen
ihr habt bestimmt noch ganz viele andere
tricks die bei euch gegen blattläuse
geholfen haben da bin ich immer ganz
gespannt und ich denke die anderen
zuschauer freuen sich auch total damals
von euch zu hören also lasst gerne einen
kommentar da und erzählte niemals was
ihr gegen blattläuse unternehmen und was
bei euch gut geholfen hat ich hoffe das
video hat euch gefallen und
weitergeholfen eurer plot lage herr zu
werden
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lasst gerne einen daumen nach oben da
das hilft mir und meinem kanal ungemein
weiter wenn ihr rund ums jahr mit garten
tipps versorgt werden wollt dann
abonniert den kanal wir sprechen hier
ganz viel über das thema gemüsegarten
jetzt steht ja auch bald die haltbar
macht sie so an da kommen jetzt auch
ganz viele spannende videos also trägt
den abo button und auch die glocke damit
ihr informiert werdet wenn ein neues
video erscheint ich poste
samstags um 10 ein neues video ich freue
mich wenn du nächste woche wieder mit
dabei bin ist bis dann nach gut ist dass
eine dumme überleitung schnitt so
überhaupt nicht ein bisschen kleben
bleiben und wollte einfach nur wissen
buch marie nicht mal alles abreißen
regen geil geil mücken gern mögen es ist
so und nicht gemütlich im gewächshaus
wenn es draußen wird hier überhaupt
nicht gehen dabei werde ich schon lange
fertig mit meinem video vielleicht
sollte ich noch ein paar tomaten aus
geizen einfach nur damit ich noch ein
bisschen hier bleiben kann
[Musik]